-Welcome back.
It is always great to see you.
Thank you for taking some time
to say hi to us.
Congrats on the new album,
by the way.
You just dropped this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Crushed it with this.
No one knew it was going to
come out.
I guess you knew
it was going to come out.
-Obviously.
-Yeah, yeah.
How long ago did you know, like,
"Oh, yeah,
I'm going to release this"?
-Um...
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Since I started to work on it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah -- Yeah, that's true.
I understand that.
But to come out now,
I know you like to give little
Easter eggs
and hints to your fans.
But you, like, just dropped it
out of nowhere.
-Yeah, well, they already know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What does the title mean again?
-"Nadie sabe lo que va
a pasar mañana," that means
like nobody knows what is going
to happen tomorrow.
I guess you know.
[ Cheers ]
-Nobody knows
what's going to happen tomorrow.
-Yeah, nobody knows.
-It became the most
streamed album
in a single day
this year on Spotify.
It's already breaking
all these records.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking Spanish ]
-It's great. It is so great.
-Feels good.
-22 tracks.
It's unbelievable.
You had a listening party
in Puerto Rico
and here's your entrance.
16,000 people.
You entered -- You came from
the roof in a Rolls Royce.
I mean, being lowered
from the ceiling.
Were you scared at all?
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
A little bit, yeah.
But I had fun. It was --
-You always do fun things,
by the way.
-Yeah.
-I know I saw the video
from Monaco, you had
a special guest with you.
-Who's that?
-I'm talking about Al Pacino.
-Aw, look.
-Yeah, not too shabby, bud.
You and Al Pacino --
you even included
a little moment in this video
which I want to show everyone.
Just a little piece.
Can we take a look at this?
-[ Laughs ]
How's it going?
-Playing games.
What else is new?
Hey, you're doing great.
-Thank you.
-You really are doing great.
He's charging it up.
They wrote a song.
♪ You never know
what tomorrow brings ♪
-[ Vocalizes ]
-♪ Never know what tomorrow
takes from you ♪
-I mean, come on.
That's Al Pacino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How cool is that?
-That was amazing.
That was a great experience
working with Al Pacino.
That was very exciting.
-How did you get hooked up
with Al Pacino?
-Well, I don't even know
if people know,
Al Pacino is my uncle.
-Oh, my gosh.
I didn't know that.
That's amazing.
I didn't know that at all.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
No.
Actually, I don't know
how we connect with him.
But --
[ Laughter ]
I'm very grateful 'cause
that was a dream come true.
-Yeah. He's a legend.
He's the best.
-He's a legend.
I love his movies.
"Scarface", "Godfather",
"Carlito's Way."
I love him.
-Yeah, everything he does --
-It was just
a very special day for me.
-You just released that you
have -- this afternoon,
actually, you announced that
you're going on tour again.
-I did?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have to.
Yes.
-Are you sure?
-Yes. It's happening this next
year, I think, in February.
Yeah, you'll be --
[ Cheers and applause ]
All over North America.
-Yes, I'm very happy.
-But isn't that work for you?
Isn't that like -- Do you like
performing and going on tour?
-I love perform-- Yeah,
of course I love performing.
It's my -- I think -- I love
to create at the studio.
But I think to perform
to the people
is my favorite thing
about the music.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Like, what part?
Is it when people sing
the song back to you?
-Yes.
I think that's the best
feeling ever.
Like --
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I missed it.
I missed it.
-Yeah, we need you, bud.
It's great.
You know, since we've known
each other,
you just watched your career
just go skyrocketing.
It's awesome.
I'm so happy for you.
There's actually college courses
teaching about you at colleges.
"Bad Bunny, race, gender,
empire, and reggaeton"
at Wellesley College.
"Bad Bunny and resistance"
in Puerto Rico"
is Loyola Marymount University.
Did you ever think
you were going to be taught --
a course at a school?
-Noooooo.
[ Laughter ]
No.
-Is that cool?
-That's a very crazy thing.
I'm still --
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Sometimes people came to me
like,
"Yeah, I'm taking this class
about you."
I'm like, "What? Really?"
I don't know.
Feels weird.
But I would love to take
one of those classes.
[ Laughter ]
-You'll be really good.
-I think I would get an A.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You would ace that.
You would get an A
in that course.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-You know everything about
Bad Bunny.
Absolutely, yeah.
I didn't get a chance
to tell you
how great you were
at the Grammys, by the way.
This is you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before you won your third
Grammy, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-But I heard that this
wasn't supposed to be
the opening of the Grammys.
Is that true?
-That's true.
How you know that?
-Because I do research.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Al Pacino is my uncle.
-That's true, that's true.
It wasn't supposed to be
the opening act.
But I think -- I don't know.
I guess the producer saw it
at the rehearsal.
And he said like, "This is
the best thing about the night."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-When you do those shows,
awards shows, like do you get --
is it a little bit
different crowd because you see
like Taylor Swift
and Jack Harlow dancing to you?
-I don't care.
Like, it's fine.
-It's fine. It's the same.
But is that the same
as when you --
-It's the same. Taylor likes
to dance to everybody's music.
[ Laughter ]
So, I know she's gonna be
like be --
And --
-She'll be there for you, yeah.
And she'll be moving
around for you.
But when you do that
or when you did
Yankee Stadium, by the way.
Did you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I preferred
Yankee Stadium, of course.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How'd that feel?
-That was another --
a very special day in my life
'cause New York
always feels, like, special,
feels like home.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Like, it's weird.
It's something very special
being far from Puerto Rico
but it feels like
you are in home.
There's a lot of Puerto Rican,
there's a lot of Dominicans.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking Spanish ]
So every New York show is
a very special show to me,
and the New York Yankee Stadium
was something
that I'm never going to forget.
-Two sold-out shows,
not too shabby, bud.
And now you're taking part of
another iconic part of New York.
You're hosting and musical guest
on "Saturday Night Live."
Double duty. Double whammy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Double down. Double down.
Man, that's a lot of work!
It's a lot of work.
How does it feel, though,
going in?
You got some funny sketches?
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But I need to sleep.
-No. No, this is when you have
to just stay awake.
Because that's the whole
secret of "Saturday Night Live."
Like, when I was on that show,
I never --
I went to bed every night
at probably 3:00 in the morning,
just so when it's 11:30,
I'm like ready to go.
I would sleep during
the day, man.
It was crazy.
-Nah, it's crazy.
But I've been
enjoying the process.
All the cast, the producers,
the writers.
The vibe is a very cool vibe
so I'm grateful.
And I'm very excited
about this Saturday.
This Saturday?
-Yeah, this Saturday.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're already getting
the word down that
everyone loves you up there.
And you're just like,
"Dude, he's the nicest guy."
Everyone's freaking out.
And they're like,
"It's a great, funny show."
So, congrats.
We'll all be watching.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
-No, it'll be great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be watching Bad Bunny.
Check him out on
"Saturday Night Live."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This weekend,
the host and musical guest.
We'll be right back
with Charli D'Amelio.
Stick around, everybody!